did you teach Will Smith
this yeah yeah did he use your slap
moves if you notice right it it would
have sold from any angle notice that was
nobody notices that he did a 540 after
[Music]
that welcome back to another sick ass
part two episode of getting to know
Jeremy over here with off the Record
here's the thing man uh we were so
[__] fascinated cuz all of us are
little boys who like grew up loving
people like Jackie Channon stuff so you
being here like I haven't seen the room
this excited in a long time where we're
just like tell us more [__] what else
happened you see the movie right like
this is what we you watch the movie this
is what you fall in love with but the
[__] like depth behind of what it
takes like that's your world so it's
cool till we get to go like what's
behind there so just to give some fans a
quick catch up you were a stunt
coordinator on John Wick I was a fight
coordinator a fight coordinator on John
Wick he gives like a really quick just
spicy little like list of credits of
things you've done that you've been
proud of let know what it is John Wick
for I just did I just got to do um
Silent Night with John wo that should be
coming out soon what what is that give
us the DS give us the Deets technically
are we allowed I can't talk about it
we're on is that a Christmas movie oh
you're on strike yeah oh [__] this is
coming out in December oh wait that's
right is it I don't know I've just made
that no no we don't know if it'll ever
come out so I mean for me like the the
ones that are proud are not always cuz
they're great movies either it's just
things like I got to work with John then
I did Gemini man with Ang Lee that's
cool dope well did it do great but I got
to Will Smith yeah yeah yeah um dang did
you teach Will Smith
this yeah yeah did he use your slap
moves if you notice right it it would
have sold from any angle notice that it
was nobody notices that he did a 540
after that's true it was caught on all
cameras no my I got to do one of the
Avengers so I think I did Civil War
that's cool I got to do Venom I got to
doam uh Ninja Turtles was my favorite
cuz that's cool it was me anise Danny
Graham Jackson Fel John Vera JoJo usio
like which Ninja Turtles um the the
first one of the animated one the the
first one with the live action Michael B
one yeah the one where they like
suddenly look all mature and like [__]
the scary Turtles Turtles the weird ones
but like for us we were just like in map
suits with the with a map turtle back
and we're just like which Turtle were
you so cool I was Michelangelo you
mangelo yeah yeah so that was that was
one of my favorite cuz you know we just
got to be in New York and our best
friends doing Turtle [__] yeah it was
dream dream come true right that's
[__] cool um that's [__] cool man
yeah and then I got to fight Scott
Atkins on another like really low which
one low lowbudget film that he did
called close range but then the director
was Isaac Florentine who did the
original Power Rangers so like a lot of
the projects were like just cool to do
because of like the people I got to meet
and work it's almost like like dream
teams and does Almost Doesn't Matter
What the project is just the dream te
exactly exactly what was your favorite
final product that actually that came
out probably John MC that's cool that
[__] was amazing that [__] was so
[__] cool to see I actually got to
watch wake four with Jeremy at Burbank
like got a Premiere or n it was just we
went to go to a like a regular show I
think they wanted to do some like o
thing we end up just watching the movie
we're like oh my God Jeremy the whole
time Nick Nick Nick this is me this is
me no honestly I would be I would Nick
the whole time is that you is that you
is that you Jeremy is that you did that
hurt did that hurt I'm just talking
hella loud but there was this one scene
where he does this crazy really cool j
Jitsu move and I'm like oh I'm like the
only one [__] oh because you know
what it is and Jeremy's like yeah what
you think what you think that was pretty
[__] cool or they like we'll see
Jeremy on screen we're like oh [__]
that's him I'm like babe just Jeremy we
were watching it with Jeremy she's like
yeah okay I got it and she's like oh my
God so many gunshots I think I was like
drunk on mules too so I was just acting
like an idiot but it was so fun though I
like the idea of you looking out for
Jiu-Jitsu based moves and then being
excited but everything else you're
like he Incorporated the rear naked
choke I was like I've never seen it done
like that before but no honestly for
sure though it's like it's how do you
make a Kimura look
dope was that actual
question like these moves are like tons
of people that specialize in that stuff
too well you know Dave Camaro yeah he's
the [__] Legend he was in it with us
he was helping um train Keanu but he's
like the king of he's the arm collector
like he does a really cool uh version
where if you know a lot of people they
sit back and they lean back on their
hand when they're fighting open guard
and you're if you're standing and he
does like a dive roll over the person
and all almost always people try to like
time you going back but you can dive
roll over the arm and steal the kamora
so by the time your back hits you turn
back into them and then you chicken wing
them like you mount their head very
aesthetically pleasing but it's one of
my favorite ones to do and then for
camera my f one of my favorite curas to
do is like like if they take your back
and you do the Cur from in the front and
then you turn into them and you get them
like you throw them from a cur right
like those are fun that's so cool
anytime their legs go overhead that's
cool oh yeah and they you see the two
legs flip in the air what's like a a
stunt that you had to get ready for that
was the most like [__] thing that
you've ever been most nervous about or
had to do the most prep for or just the
most dangerous okay there's something I
did on my first movie your first movie
oh [__] all called Expendables right oh
[__] [__] first movie that was the first
movie and what was funny was I was
getting ready for Tron with anise and
then the director wanted like everybody
over 6 foot so Chad looks at me he's
sorry and I was like he's like you can
come to Expendables with me though it's
like all right and Chad was like
literally in the airport going there he
was like he's like you know you're a
stunt man now don't think you're going
to be like a famous actor you're going
to be I'm going to try to kill you and
you try to survive that was like what he
said and I was like
[__] dude he he threw me in the mix like
obviously he just scaring me but he
threw me in the mix and there was this
one day where I was I had to do a
ratchet like a 20 foot ratchet which is
like um a Pneumatic like like um like a
cable that drags you or something yeah
it's it's got like um I can't talk right
now don't you press a button it you
press a button and it's got like you
could set the pounds of force like it
just jerks you across yeah and it jerks
you so you don't have a guy pulling you
so it's
faster all mechanical yeah and you get a
lot more snap off the top so like like a
chiropractor yeah it sucks and what
sucks is the opposite when you do it
like you just okay well where am I
supposed to land and I mean you you do a
bunch of stuff to to get ready for it
and you know where you're going to land
but when you go 3 2 1 go like there's no
lag you're like you're there and then
you're there depending on how fast you
go so I had to do that and then there
was a scene where I had to do um five
deaths in one but we were shooting um
like uh infrared like thermal goggles
and I had to fight Randy Couture was a
different scene and then um I remember
the the changing room was like A4 mile
away so I was like running and halfway
through on the walkie they're like
Jeremy Chad's looking for you on set I'm
like [__] so I I take off my [__] and I
run back and I I remember walking in a
set and it was like this uh cargo ship
for pirates like sman Pirates and the
whole thing is like they're infiltrating
this this ship and I look up and Chad is
like on the set of stairs that kind of
it's like those metal graded stairs on a
ship yeah and it goes like that and he's
like three of three of those up three
flights of stairs three flights that
like the ones that go up in a square and
he's just like standing there like this
and I'm like like oh [__] so I start
walking up and I'm looking around and
I'm brand new to the the stunt industry
and there's like 60 stunt guys oh sh and
I walk up and he goes um he goes I want
you to run up these stairs Terry Crew is
going to shoot you with a shotgun I want
you to do over the railing and the
railing was like up to here cuz it was
like a cargo ship so it was like that
instead of being down here and since I'm
running I can't just like put my foot on
a platform to prep yeah it's like I want
you to take the shot do a Arabian which
is like a a half twisting backflip and
then I want you to land on that cargo
box and I look down the cargo box like 8
feet like okay no
problem I look at it and the first thing
is when I walk out of the shower I'm
don't slip don't slip
Ser guys walking same arm same leg
too [__] chameleon speed so I'm 19
the the it's metal grades right so like
one of my older my my uncle Danny
Hernandez he's like hey youngster I was
like what's up he goes look at this
thing he's showing me something so if
you go over the railing um the platforms
that you walk on have like metal um
metal edges oh [__] he go we should pad
that up and I was like
yeah I didn't even think about it cuz he
was like when you go over rails and you
topple over everybody thinks you just
shoot out but if you put your hip just
it's like a judo throw it just becomes a
fulro oh so your head just goes like
that so in my head I'm like now I could
be hitting my head on a metal grate and
the big rule in stuns is like wherever
you put the pads is where you don't land
like you know if you do a car hit and
you put all your pads on you always
injure the one part you don't have pads
so I'm like I'm going to [__] this up
somehow so I do a couple of these right
and it's just 8ft fall so it's not a big
deal that's crazy to say and cuz that's
already from what like ceiling like this
right
eight dude that's awful what are you
talking
about it was like it was to a cargo box
like a shipping container I don't care
dude able to hide a mat on there right
so we put a mat there is it like a nice
bed mattress or like no it's like a
gymnastics M that's
nauy it's like this but that wasn't the
hard part though so I was like after the
whole day of like doing all these crazy
stunts I'm rushed into this part he's
like okay do this I tried a couple times
maybe two or three times and I'm
watching all the like the legendary
stump people that are there and I'm like
don't [__] this up don't [__] this up
and then they're okay let's shoot and
then I hear Jeremy so I come back behind
Monitor and um Hank Amos is like hey
youngster Chad doesn't think you can do
this but I have $300 betting that you
can and I was like what he goes instead
of landing on the cargo box I want you
to chip off the cargo box
which was like it was another 12T from
the floor what the [__] and then he was
I want you to chip off of it do like a
Hong Kong twist and then if you can try
to clip that box to slow yourself down
and then hit the concrete what the [__]
so it was 12 ft from the the container
to the um to another small like 4 foot
cargo box and then they were like and
then hit the deck and they were like but
if you miss cuz it it was 4T wide by 4T
tall they're like if you miss you just
land 12T to concrete so try not to miss
try just try and I was like I could do
it and he was like I thought you could I
thought you could and in my head I'm
like oh I'm going to get [__] up like
oh
[__] I was like would you like me to
rehearse it and Chad looks at me like
you [__] idiot why would you rehearse
that you just get up there oh my God but
the thing is like a lot of times when
you do WI gags or car hits if you can
like stand in the spot where it's going
to happen then you just like sit there
and pray I had to run up the stairs and
hit a
mark anything happens so they're
shooting you from the stairs part yeah
you have so much pressure on you right
now you got 300 bucks on it yeah and
Chad was like they're like okay
everybody go to one so I'm like at
number one and then Chad goes Jeremy and
I look over and he was don't [__] it
up and it's like the worst thing to hear
and he just walks away dude and all of
this is happening within like 20 minutes
cuz you're on set and everybody's like
go go go go go like and I'm 19 first
movie just like this is
crazy is this a little bit you said
there's like 60 other legendary stuntman
there but they're pulling like the
19-year-old who's like fresh off into
this industry like some hazing sh yeah
just a little bit like that like it
could have almost used anybody who's
sick as [__] or maybe they don't even
want to do it well the the older guys
yeah I mean the older guys were like
older and they're like they don't want
to get [__] up anymore like let a
young guy do it and then you look at the
young guys you go who can do it and like
this was my my test cuz you know we grew
up in the YouTube like genre where
everybody's trying to be a stun person
to be cool to become an actor but back
then they were like don't promote
yourself you're a stun person your job
is to make the actor look good M so it's
not like I could just go around talking
about this [__] and like putting it out
there and and um this isn't a talk show
yeah so so sure enough like 3 2 one
action I run up and I just remember
looking up and Terry Cruz is like Bove
and I go and I go and it happened in
slowmo cuz I I'm watching the metal
great and I'm going I'm glad we put a
pad
there and I'm like oh I should probably
ditch my gun so I like Dro my gun but
I'm doing this flip and like this is all
happening like that wow I throw my gun I
clip and I remember feeling the corner
of my back like this and I go that was
perfect and like I just start spinning
and I'm like where's the Box where's the
box I see the box and I just try to like
get whatever I could on it oh my God hit
the box I slowed myself down hit the
concrete and I went that wasn't that
bad in the scene everybody's running in
my God and one of the old school guys
I'm playing dead right and one of the
old school guys runs up and he's
shooting and he looks down he goes nice
one youngster Stomps on my
chest that's what hurt the most why did
he do that he was Hing me he's like nice
one youngster Wham just takes off
military and I'm
like you don't want to like you don't
want to have to go again right cuz
they're like oh the dead guy was alive
so
like that's true [__] I didn't think
about that
cuz at the last one if he goes ow and
then they're like cut do it again holy
[__]
ow why you do that and then that was
like one of those like cuz the you know
the the the toxic masculinity guys back
in the day who were like you know you
have to just man up yeah they they you
know after that show they were like I
think I think this is where you become a
man like you're a man now though that's
like you place in like yeah yeah it was
cooling crazy dude that's earning it
though man that's earning it D the extra
stomp at the end are you now the stomper
on set yeah I like to do the thing where
if you're doing background fighting like
we were in Hawaii last year on a Mamoa
project and all the new people are there
they're like trying to prove themselves
and we'd be like fighting with axes or
something and they go 3 two I go hey
they're what I take their weapon I lob
it across the set and we're on like lava
rocks just lob it action I'm like he
like but we're in like the Deep
background what you just do funny [__]
like that it's hell yeah we have a lot
of fun man that's so funny are there um
cuz looking at my son now since he was a
kid I think he was he'd like to get beat
up like I have videos of him two or
three just like like he's like like
touch me Papa and I touch him
goes throws himself against the couch
are there kids stunt programs I don't
know if there's stunt programs like I
think nobody wants to deal with that
liability but there
nightmare you should start it start it
dude yeah I I mean kid stun kid St get
lean get strong get [__] up I just
want it's good to learn how to face your
fears when you don't have a lot of fears
yet right and when you're a kid so you
get the you know when you're an adult
and you're like I don't want to do that
like you can get rid of that really fast
and you can
confidently right like the most the most
dangerous guys to fight are the guys who
got their asses kicked and
survived right so like the people who
are like 30 years old and they're like I
grew up in South Central and there were
stabbings and shootings all the time
like you can't hurt that guy right so in
this world that we live in where we're
all protecting our kids like where do
they get to learn how to face that
adrenaline and then control it yeah like
there's not unless there you know
parkour for me I always say like Free
Runners are the the best martial arts
like artists these days because they
don't just stand behind their their
their martial arts and go oh yeah I
could do this and I could poke your eyes
out could poke your eyes out but like I
don't want to go to jail so I can't
really show you right yeah I want to go
to jail I've gotten a bunch of those
martial artists who are scared to do
stunts cuz they're I'm like I thought
you control your body and you control
your emotions but then you get a
freerunner who like actively looks down
and sees like 50 stories and they go I'm
going to be fine and then they do the
dangerous stunt and then they're alive
right yeah so when I have them on set
they're like everything's easy and
you're like oh this is how it should be
and nobody's like like freaking out but
then you do get some martial artists who
are not really that great at stunts we
should do more par fights and stunts are
two different things yeah very scary
yeah like and and like I'm kind of one
of the guys that like gets to float and
do everything so so it's really it's
really fun I don't drive as much I like
riding my motorcycle but I don't that's
one thing I won't [__] with because not
driving motorcycle riding like like like
motorcycle stunts like subin like crazy
guy yeah like I'm learning I can learn
wheelies and stuff like that like I can
get it up but I won't I won't I can't
even get it up he's talking about his
penis yeah I got that out of the stunt
drivers who's the scariest Asians or
non-asians stunt drivers yeah yeah who
the scares to work with like you have a
St and you see an Asian driver you're
like no let uh F Asian Grand swap them
out real quick no you know what dude in
the states for the most part I know most
of the people in the states and they're
like they're pretty pretty good it's
when you go to a different country and
you're like in Bulgaria or some [__] and
they're like this is is uh this is
whoever he's best drifter in Bulgaria
and you're like what and you're when
you're meeting locals in places that you
never heard of people and they don't
have a reputation so you don't know how
they're going to at least they don't we
don't know them but they might have a
reputation in wherever they're from so
you just got to be like [__] it I just
met you and they're just going to hit me
in a car well see I won't do it I won't
do that ah yeah those are the things I
say no to cuz it's like backyard
wrestlers like you don't know he might
be number one in my country but then
their movie film is like everybody died
yeah it's Undisputed for everybody died
on only two Stu men died he's number one
cuz the other last month last month I
like the idea of the kid stunt thing
though yeah stunt for kid ever since he
was a kid he always liked the even in
Jiu-Jitsu class you know when they they
teach a move right he wants to be on the
receiving end always so when they go
like most kids they go I want to do the
throw he's already like throw me
and he just is he like Wim Blow from
kungpow yes Wim Wim I'm bleeding that
makes me the
Victor do you think it's a good idea to
to like make an action movie where every
time there's fights when it when the guy
gets hit it cuts to a kid getting
hit a stunt kid just for the stuns stunt
kid just wow it's jaw Wick just the
stuns though bringing the kid bringing
the kid baby in a suit bringing the stun
kid that actually actually that' be
hilarious be so cute just do a YouTube
like short like that's that's
video bwan just murdering
kids it's like it's like uh Anchor Man
when he keeps punching the babies yeah
or Step Brothers just kidding news
careful boys is a brand just kidding
news is the man of smart people the
people of just kidding news careful boys
they are very smart just kiding news the
number one forcast in the world
world